back at the Falls and you can see where
it starts up there and I'm gonna perch
the pizza curiously here don't want to
fall over these little Falls are going
into the Gulf here but the Dooleys sort
of powerful not because we've had a bit
of rain the last couple of days I mean
again it's not as much as it was
yesterday but it's pounding
it's absolutely pounding and it's quite
spectacular
to see you know the ports of his water
just pounding down there hour after hour
after hour carving its way through the
forest and of course we are we have a
today quite pleasant to be once again
walking with my buddy Jordy where are
you Jordy I want you in the picture
hey Gordie give us a nice there you are
Gordie nice dog such a nice looking dog
yeah beautiful dogs in this pond every
day I think so
alright how's your Korean coming along
sorry five so here we are a little bit
closer to the balls
the water
my roof out my stairway back into the
forest and Gordy doesn't go this way he
goes some by the way that much faster
and better but that's my route here we
are somewhat upstream from the Falls on
the bridge
you know I can stand here and watch the
water flow by all day long he is crazy
right
Forrest
and of cards there we have the water
rushing down the top of the Falls I'm
not about to take a canoe over the
here that's for sure and we will now
continue our our walk
sorry Gordy and the pictures today okay
hi there day 75 15 days to go basically
two weeks I feel good I think I'm on the
downhill path here I was in the woods
today listening to Kim Yuna's podcast a
new one that I hadn't read or gone
through I could make out a more and more
of what he's saying when I got home and
I started going through the text on
length which I've got here there's fewer
and fewer words that I have to create
links for when I go to the iPad now even
if I look at something that I haven't
gone through saving words for I can I
can read through it based on words that
I've already saved some of which I have
learned and I'm enjoying it I'm enjoying
the podcast there were a couple there
that have too many poems in it that kind
of I got stuck but now these most recent
ones there are more interesting to me
and Allah and I know in fact I've also
got a transcriber working on some blogs
excuse me some podcasts relate to
politics so I'm gonna do some of those
as well and and really I mean it's just
a matter of staying on course two weeks
I'll be a little bit as I am now
eventually to get really good I got to
stay with it that's that's just the
nature of language learning but I feel
that I already feel that my my 90-day
challenge that extra effort that extra
you know impetus has brought me over the
hump and if I hadn't done that then I
wouldn't be as far along conceivably if
I hadn't gone to San Diego and if I
hadn't got very sort of fascinated by
all the events in Ukraine I'd be a
little further along but it doesn't
matter I'm doing things that I enjoy
doing I enjoy following events in
Ukraine I enjoy following Kim Yuna's
podcast I enjoy walking the dog in the
bush so today's a good day plus I found
a Korean language meetup group here in
vain
Coover so i contacted them and the
message came back there like a
three-page list of questions you know
why are you studying Korean this is not
a dating service blah blah blah kind of
asking for my bona fide ease which I
provided so we'll see how far that takes
us and I'm gonna be trying to get a hold
of mr. Kim or sees mr. Chae my golfing
buddy
although I haven't golfed since last
fall and see if we can get together and
talk some Korean so all of this is gonna
happen over the next 15 days and we'll
just see how far it takes me five or now